évidemment l'enseignement est très mal
adaptés et ça ne peut plus durer comme
ça et c'est pour cela que nous désirons
une réforme mais une vraie réforme pas
une réformette de plus à l'emphase de ce
problème
il y a deux solutions il y en a une qui
est facile c'est la solution
spectaculaire on descend dans la rue et
puis on se contente de dire ce qui ne va
pas sans rien proposer
et puis il ya une seconde solution c'est
la nôtre alors bien sûr elle est
beaucoup plus discrète mais elle est
aussi beaucoup plus efficace alors cette
solution c'est tout simplement la
concertation parce que finalement cette
réforme avant tout elle doit être celle
de tous les lycéens et de tous les
collégiens
alors pour une fois qu'un ministre
propose la concertation le dialogue et
le débat national où s'il une réforme
importante et bien nous nous l'acceptons
bien sûr tout n'est pas parfait dans
cette réforme
et c'est pourquoi nous avons créé dans
toute la france des comités pour la
réforme de l'enseignement pour en parler
et puis pour peut-être faire de
nouvelles propositions et puis pour
pouvoir en parler librement sans être
une fois de plus récupérer
l'enseignement bien sûr ça n'est qu'un
exemple il ya des tas d'autres problèmes
[Musique]